une émission émission radio luber
présente avec un peu de nostalgie les
émissions d'autrefois présentant dans la
nuit
il est alerté par des voies qui mercredi
dernier dans la nuit c'était une femme
qui l'appelait pour lui dire qu'elle
voulait en finir avec la vie et hubert a
tenté de la sauver et la sauver et
gilles grossman lui demande de raconter
justement ce sauvetage
c'était oui c'était s'était d'abord des
sanglots et bon dernier moment il ya le
petit fils qui est le dernier qui aurait
dit quelqu'un la vie il faut que les
sanglots deviennent des mots deviennent
une explication un début de vidage du
sac est ce qu'elle me dit c'est que
c'est que c'est fini que le ciel lui
tombe sur la tête que chaque malheur qui
peut arriver à alain s'accumuler pendant
cascade sur l essai c'est l'horreur
qu'elle est à un point où elles n'osent
même plus raconter son histoire
tellement c'est énorme et de la peur
qu'on lui ait donné elles sont fermées
et l aval de l'histoire et d'autres
choses et et à partir de ce moment là il
faut pas il faut pas alors il n'y a pas
une espèce de deux coups de coeur
collectif tout le téléphone est bloqué
tout le monde appelle tout le monde lui
parle comme on la tient à bout de voix
comme ça et il vous dit de quoi on lui
dit d'abord il faut la persuader
physiquement de recracher ce qu'elle a
appris ça finit par arriver
et là je sais qu'elle a basculé du côté
de la vie et à un moment les auditeurs
de repente amener de l'argent
puisqu'elle avait un problème de dette
et huissiers c'est un appel de votre
passé soit 97
c'est les gens qui ont appelé en disant
bon moi j'envoie de l'argent pendant ce
temps d'autres arrivent et ceux qui
étaient les plus proches sont arrivées
anonymement comme ça en demandant à la
sécurité de les accompagner
ils apportaient leur billet de 50 francs
leur billet de 100 francs leur petit
chèque en soi pointe des pieds en dix
ans
je réside en une demi heure
le problème financier était réglé c'est
fou c'est pas nous c'est pas moi c'est
ces gens fabuleux qui ont fait ça c'est
eux qui ont tout fait
c'est tellement rassurant de vivre dans
un monde comme ça magnifique et là il
fallait y aller et on y est allé et on
va tout concrétiser bien sûr sur place
qu'est ce que ça fait du bien vous vous
souvenez de son visage ouais de tous ces
visages remercier tous ceux qui m'ont
soutenu hier pendant très difficile pour
moi
[Musique]